[Musik]
es ist der neunte november 1918 hier vom
west balkon des reichstages wie philipp
scheidemann die deutsche republik aus
die weimarer republik war die erste
parlamentarische demokratie in
deutschland eine bewegte zeit
die junge republik werte nur 14 jahre
und endete in der diktatur der
nationalsozialisten nach dem
verheerenden zweiten weltkrieg mit
millionen toten und den holocaust wurde
erst 1949 mit der bundesrepublik wieder
eine demokratische staatsform in
deutschland etabliert einigkeit und
recht und freiheit in ganz deutschland
gab es sogar erst wieder seit der
wiedervereinigung im jahre 1990 was
erinnert heute noch an die weimarer
republik was verbindet uns mit der
ersten deutschen demokratie welche
aktualität hat die geschichte der
weimarer republik haben wir etwa wieder
weimarer verhältnisse
das wollen wir heraus sind begleiten sie
mich auf einer spannenden zeitreise 100
jahre später auf den spuren
herbst 1918 das deutsche kaiserreich hat
den ersten weltkrieg verloren die
urkatastrophe des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts millionen tote soldaten und
zivilisten sind zu beklagen die
kriegswirtschaft ist am boden
matrosen in wilhelmshaven und kiel
verweigern einen befehl zum auslaufen
die aufstände erreichen berlin
es kommt zur revolution der kaiser muss
abdanken
es bilden sich arbeiter und soldatenräte
aus denen der rat der volksbeauftragten
entsteht
die vorzeichen für den neuen staat
stehen nicht gut die hypothek des
kaiserreichs ist hoch der versailler
vertrag besiegelt die deutsche
niederlage kriegsschuld und
reparationszahlungen lasten schwer
es herrschen ständig unruhen aufstände
von links und rechts bedrohen die
republik die menschen leiden unter der
inflation in berlin herrschen
bürgerkriegsähnliche zustände
erste priorität wahlen zu einer
nationalversammlung die eine verfassung
ausarbeiten soll
weimar die stadt von goethe und schiller
der inbegriff deutscher kultur 1918 eine
beschauliche kleinstadt
hier findet die nationalversammlung
statt
weimar wenn plötzlich für genau 100 97
tage politischer mittelpunkt des landes
eine ausstellung im stadtmuseum weimar
macht diese zeit lebendig dr alfred nah
ist leiter des stadtmuseums weimar und
stellvertretender vorsitzender des
vereins weimarer republik er wissen
warum fand denn die nationalversammlung
überhaupt in der ich sag jetzt mal
provinz stadt weimar statt und nicht in
der reichshauptstadt berlin
reichshauptstadt berlin und münchen wäre
nicht gegangen diese ressentiments
zwischen preußen und bayern den wir
natürlich allgemein bekannt es musste
eine sozusagen neutrale stadt sein weil
man eine kleine stadt in thüringen lag
zentral im deutschen reich sie hat diese
bedingungen der neutralität erfüllt die
stadt war sehr gut zu erreichen man
hatte also gute bahnverbindungen es gab
sogar eine fluglinie diese stadt war
sehr gut abzusperren ein wesentliches
argument war auch dass hier kein
proletariat vorhanden war es gab also
nicht die gefahr revolutionärer unruhen
die sozusagen diese nationalversammlung
dann behindert hätten und last but not
least dass man dieses nationaltheater
hatte das großherzogliche hoftheater
wurde in dem umfeld der
nationalversammlung umbenannt in
deutsches nationaltheater weimar und da
hatte man eben auch die möglichkeit
diese tagung in ruhe durchführen zu
können
der geist von weimar war nicht
vordergründig das thema zwar nicht so
goethe und schiller waren hier und
deswegen geht man nach weimar die
menschen in weimar waren ja nur nicht
mehr untertan wie im gesamten deutschen
reich sondern bürger was hat es denn mit
ihnen gemacht
auf jeden fall war die revolution ein
umbruch aber man muss auch wissen weil
man sehr konservativ viele beamte waren
hier viele hof diener
man hat es auch gemerkt dass die
nationalversammlung dann natürlich
erstmal dazu führte dass wir mal wieder
eine bedeutsame stadt war aber man
glaubte das geht nur einige wochen
das hat dann monate gedauert die coolen
wurden knapp die kartoffeln waren sogar
mal alle das heißt also die bevölkerung
hat doch einen ziemlichen unmut dann
entwickelt und man hat auch noch nicht
verstanden dass die demokratie
eben nicht über nacht entsteht dass das
ein langer prozess ist sie sind ja auch
stellvertretende vorsitzende des vereins
weimarer republik mit dem projekt das
haus der weimarer republik als
nationaler erinnerungsort das soll ja 20
19 eröffnet werden was können sie uns
dazu erzählen
dieses forum für demokratie zu einer
ausstellung zeigen zur
nationalversammlung zur weimarer
republik
es soll eine forschungsstelle dort
etabliert werden die sich mit den
ergebnissen beschäftigt was hat weimar
uns gebracht was ist heute noch aktuell
und als drittes museumspädagogik
führungen diskussionen
veröffentlichungen werden dort aus
diesem haus kommen ein ganz wichtiges
symbol der weimarer republik und her ist
eine deutsche demokratie wählt ihr die
farben schwarz rot gold die sind ja zum
ersten mal hier in weimar offiziell
gehisst worden vor dem nationaltheater
denkt man sich eigentlich dass die heute
auch noch wen diese fahren ja das ist
natürlich auch eine wesentliche aufgabe
dieses geschichtsbewusstsein wieder zu
schaffen
am 31 juli 19 meter schwarz-rot-gold
erste mal als staatliche flaake
deutschlands und das eine fahne der
demokratie eine fahne der grundrechte
eine fahne der werte und so findet
deutschland natürlich einen platz in
europa ein appell an uns alle dass man
schwarz rot gold nicht läuten überlässt
die die demokratie nicht schätzen dass
es eine urdemokratische fahne und als
solche sollte es die weiteste
verbreitung finden
vom modell zum geplanten standort hier
soll das haus der weimarer republik
stehen direkt gegenüber steht das
deutsche nationaltheater das wichtigste
symbol der weimarer republik eine
gedenktafel von bauhaus-gründer walter
gropius erinnert daran hier tagte 1919
für rund ein halbes jahr die
nationalversammlung um eine verfassung
auszuarbeiten
die neue verfassung wurde nach 86
sitzungen am 31.7 1919 mit großer
mehrheit verabschiedet und trat am 14.8
1919 in kraft der jenaer
politikwissenschaftler professor michael
dreyer leitet die forschungsstelle
weimarer republik und ist vorsitzender
des vereins weimarer republik ev wir
müssen wir uns denn ganz generell die
politische wie wirtschaftliche die
gesellschaftliche situation in
deutschland an der jahreswende 18 19
vorstellen dieses katastrophal
der krieg ist verloren aber die blockade
geht weiter dass die lebensmittel
situation ist nach wie vor schlimm
und das ist ja jetzt nicht der erste
hunger winter sondern das ist der zweite
dritte vierte folge wo die
versorgungslage der bevölkerung wirklich
schwierig ist die chance dass man da
jetzt raus kommt die wird enthusiastisch
aufgenommen von der bevölkerung eine
immer stärkere belastung der jungen
republik war ja die sogenannte
dolchstoßlegende
das deutsche heer sei von hinten von der
revolutionierenden heimat erwischt
worden wie sehen sie das
das ist eine methode von hindenburg und
ludendorff und anderen gewesen sich
selbst von der schuld reinzuwaschen dass
der krieg nicht militärisch verloren war
und es konnte in der bevölkerung deshalb
raum gewinnen weil deutschland wir haben
das ersten weltkriegs jahr unter totaler
zensur stand das heißt die menschen
haben noch im oktober 1918 uhr von
siegreichen abwehrschlachten geredet und
davon dass die deutschen herren
einstellen
siegreich sind und dann kam natürlich
die einblick in die sache wie es
wirklich aus als fürchterlicher schock
für die bevölkerung war es denn nicht
zuletzt der vertrag von versailles der
die neue republik so stark belastet hat
dass sie dieses gepäck immer mit sich
schleppen musste fast ebenso
problematisch wieder vertrag von
versailles selbst und die späteren
anwendungen und der seitliche zahllose
konferenzen gegeben wie die schuldenlast
geregelt werden sollen vergisst auch
häufig dass die eintreibung von belgien
frankreich england quasi nur
weitergereicht wurden an die usa
in vielen fällen den usa wieder kriegs
kredite an diese länder gezahlt und
bafin software rückzahlung je in diesem
saal sagte ja die maler
nationalversammlung
was waren denn die grundlagen der neuen
verfassung die sie formulierte nun in
einem wort gesagt ist es eine
grundlegende demokratisierung die hier
stattfindet das ist ein
parlamentarisches system in dem der
reichstag im zentrum des politischen
systems stehen soll
mit einem gewählten reichspräsidenten
einer drastischen ausweitung der
grundrechte die zum teil auch in einigen
bereichen gerade bei den sozialen und
wirtschaftlichen grundrechten weit über
das hinausgeht was im grundgesetz heute
verankert ist mal gesprochen davon dass
ist die modernste und demokratische
verfassung der welt sei und das stimmt
auch in diesem moment aber diese
verfassung war ja wie die kritiker seien
eine extrem gute verfassung aber keine
verfassung für schlechte zeiten er dann
kommen sollten
das kann man diskutieren sind sie die
schlechten zeiten die kommen ja ziemlich
schnell die kommen nicht erst 1930 das
wunder ist eigentlich nicht dass die
bäume republik am ende zerstört wurde
sondern dass sie die anfangsjahre
überlebt hat und das ist nicht zuletzt
dadurch auch möglich gewesen dass die
verfassung einem demokratischen
reichspräsidenten der aufkleben boden
der verfassung stand wie es bei
friedrich über zweifellos der fall war
möglichkeiten gab energische maßnahmen
zu ergreifen ebenfalls ein novum in der
verfassung war ja das wahlrecht für
frauen und die staatsbürgerliche
familien rechtliche gleichstellung des
frauen das war ja in europa damals nicht
selbstverständlich
unter den großen staaten der welt ist
deutschland der erste starter das
frauenwahlrecht eingeführt und soll mich
das in der verfassung sondern auch schon
im wahlgesetz national person noch
weitere errungenschaft war ja der ausbau
der sozialgesetzgebung was waren denn da
die wesentlichen punkte nun am anfang
der revolutionszeit gab es ja durchaus
die diskussion ob jetzt eine
parlamentarische demokratie oder einer
räte demokratie eingeführt werden soll
und die us pg und auch teile der spd
liebäugelt durchaus mit regel
demokratischen modell davon ist dann in
der verfassung nichts übrig geblieben
mit ausnahme allerdings dass
betriebsräte gesetzt das ist ein wenig
später verabschiedet wurde das heißt
mitbestimmung von arbeitnehmern wie für
uns heute in deutschland
selbstverständlich ist die beginnt in
der weimarer republik das ist auch
damals eine absolute neuerung grosso
modo haben wir ja schon zitiert die
weimarer verfassung war damals die
demokratischste der held zitat vom
reichsinnenminister david aber welche
strukturellen schwächen die sich ja dann
negativ ausgewirkt haben hatte sie denn
ja das ist eine schwierige frage ich bin
eigentlich gelegt und versucht zu sagen
sie hatte gar keine strukturellen
schwächen gute verfassung in schlechter
zeit gute verfassung und schlechter
elite das ist glaube ich der zentrale
unterschied zu heute
an der wiege des bonner grundgesetzes so
heißt es haben die gespenster von weimar
gestand wie war es aber damals wirklich
welche verbindung besteht zwischen
weimar und bonn zwischen der weimarer
verfassung und dem grundgesetz wir sind
in bonn im museum koenig hier wird im
lichthof am ersten september 1948 der
parlamentarische rat mit einem festakt
eröffnen die versammlung sollte nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg der drei west
alliierten eine demokratische verfassung
für die westlichen teilstaaten
ausarbeiten die eigentliche arbeit wird
woanders geleistet in der pädagogischen
akademie später ist hier der sitz des
bundesrates
65 abgeordnete darunter vier frauen
feilen an der neuen verfassung präsident
des rates wird konrad adenauer
vorsitzender der cdu in der britischen
besatzungszone und erster bundeskanzler
der bundesrepublik deutschland
am 23 mai 1949 findet in der aula in
feierlichem rahmen die unterzeichnung
und verkündung des grundgesetzes stadt
dr christina stresemann ist vorsitzende
richterin am bundesgerichtshof und zudem
enkelin des weimarer reichskanzlers
reichs außenministers und
friedensnobelpreisträgers gustav
stresemann das hier ist das faksimile
des originalen grundgesetzes von 1949
frau stritt man wie wichtig war denn die
weimarer verfassung für dieses
grundgesetz sehr wichtig denn die
weimarer verfassung war die erste
demokratische verfassung in deutschland
das hatte schon die
paulskirchenverfassung 1848 gegeben die
aber nie in kraft getreten ist und als
mann 1949 daran ging das grundgesetz zu
schaffen war natürlich die weimarer
verfassung eine vorlage im positiven wie
aber auch im negativen damals vielleicht
vor allem im negativen sinne
denn die weimarer republik war ja
gescheitert sie stand für instabilität
inflation unsicherheit und da wollte man
ja lehren aus dieser zeit aus diesem
scheitern ziehen was waren denn die
allerwichtigsten lehrern der weimarer
verfassung für das grundgesetz das
parlament und regierung gestärkt werden
müssen
diese unseligen notverordnungen die der
reichspräsident erlassen konnte was
etwas gibt es heute nicht mehr
und wenn dann der kanzler gewählt ist
und die regierung steht wird auch die
regierung bestärkt nämlich durch das
sogenannte konstruktive misstrauensvotum
in artikel 67 des grundgesetzes das
bedeutet dass das parlament den kanzler
nur abwählen kann indem es einen neuen
kanzler eine neue kanzlerin wählt das
war in weimar anders das parlament
konnte dort den kanzler das misstrauen
aussprechen dies für ihrem großvater
auch das ist in meinem großvater im
november 1923 auch passiert und dann
musste der kanzler mit der regierung
dann auch zurücktreten
man sich vorstellt die weimarer republik
dauerte 14 jahre und hatte wenn ich mal
adolf hitler weglasse zwölf verschiedene
kanzler in dieser zeit also diese
ständige abwahl der regierung das ist
natürlich alles andere als ausdruck
stabile regierungsverhältnisse was waren
denn die stärken was konnte übernommen
werden in das grundgesetz ganz wichtig
die bindung aller staatlichen gewalt an
die grundrechte auch die weimarer
verfassung hatte einen großen
grundrechtskatalog damals einzigartig
aber die grundrechte waren kein
unmittelbar geltendes recht und konnten
nicht von dem einzelnen eingefordert
werden neu gegenüber weimar der
bundesrepublik war ja auch die
einrichtung des bundesverfassungsgericht
als hüter also das ist ganz wichtig man
hat erkannt die verfassung lebt nicht
nur aus sich selbst heraus sie braucht
ein bewahrer und einen hüther und die
einrichtung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts ist ein ganz
wichtiger stützpfeiler für die
bundesrepublik
es steht als verfassungsorgan neben
bundesrat bundestag bundesregierung und
der bundespräsident
das hat eine machtfülle die im
internationalen vergleich einzigartig
ist kann man nach all dem sagen dass das
grundgesetz auch so etwas wie eine anti
weimarer verfassung war und ist die
weimarer verfassung war nicht wirklich
eine schlechte verfassung aber sie war
nicht darauf eingerichtet dass doch
große teile der bevölkerung in den 20er
jahren noch gar nicht pro demokratisch
eingestellt waren sondern noch an dem
alten obrigkeit system hingen bonn ist
nicht weimar das war ja der titel eines
buches des schweizers tritt rené
allemann aus den 50er jahren über diese
neue bundesrepublik war das gleichsam
auch der innere leitspruch dieses neuen
staates bundesrepublik bonn ist nicht
weil man auf jeden fall darf nicht
man hat weimar immer unter dem aspekt
des scheiterns gesehen und die neue
demokratie sollte unbedingt stabil
werden stabilität der
regierungsverhältnisse aber auch zum
beispiel die stabilität der d-mark ja
heute noch unter euro gesichtspunkten
ein thema auch da hatte man das
schreckgespenst weimar vor augen diese
wahnsinnige inflation ende 1923 betrug
der wert eines dollars 4,2 billionen
mark das geld war wertlos die deutschen
sollten auch die vorzüge der demokratie
kennenlernen und die vorzüge lernt man
natürlich am besten auch kennen ihn auch
wirtschaftlich stabilen verhältnissen
sogenannte wirtschaftswunder hat die
demokratie gestärkt ja auf jeden fall da
wo wirtschaftliche not herrscht ist man
ja leicht geneigt zu sagen offenbar ist
das hier nicht die richtige staatsform
und wenn chaos herrscht wünscht man sich
die ordnende hand und da hatte hitler
natürlich auch leichtes spiel das sollte
sich nicht wiederholen
nun möchten wir genauer über ihren
großvater sprechen wir gehen zum gustav
stresemann institut in bonn
gustav stresemann war vorsitzender der
deutschen volkspartei dvp 1923 wird er
reichskanzler danach außenminister in
insgesamt neun verschiedenen kabinetten
in seiner regierungszeit wird der kampf
beendet
durch die einführung der rentenmark wird
die inflation gestoppt
die verhandlungen die 1924 zum doors
plan führen erreichen einen teilweisen
schuldenerlass der reparationszahlungen
die junge republik wird gefestigt
1926 erhält stresemann zusammen mit
seinem französischen amtskollegen
aristide briand den friedensnobelpreis
für die deutsch-französische annäherung
nach der konferenz von locarno
außerdem wird deutschland in den
völkerbund aufgenommen die politische
isolation ist beendet stresemann stirbt
mit nur 51 jahren im oktober 1929
wer wann was hat ihnen ihre familie über
ihren großvater erzählt was für ein
mensch war gustav stresemann er war ja
realist in der politik und er konnte
auch seine ziele sehr hartnäckig
verfolgen und durch setzten aber die
andere seite war eine romantische eine
weiche seite
seine mutter nannte ihn traum jörg er
liebte die bücher war ein bücherwurm und
ich glaube das lesen in der einsamkeit
das hat ihn geprägt ihr großvater war ja
ein mitbegründer der deutschen
volkspartei nach dem ersten weltkrieg
wofür stand in diese partei die deutsche
volkspartei war zunächst der weimarer
republik gegenüber sehr kritisch
eingestellt
sie wollte auch den wester vertrag
revidieren anfangs auch mit
kriegerischen mitteln das warten viele
andere bis hin zur spd
philipp scheidemann sagt hier meine hand
möge verdorren wenn ich diesen vertrag
und der scheibe wurde doch
unterschrieben ja ja ja und es war eine
große belastung für die weimarer
republik aber mein großvater hat schnell
erkannt dass man eine revision nur mit
friedlichen mitteln bewerkstelligen
und doch war zeit seines politischen
lebens immer im konflikt mit der partei
im grunde genommen war die partei für
die politik die er verfolgte zu weit
rechts angesiedelt nach dem ersten
weltkrieg haben sich die liberalen
kräfte jahr neu sortiert und da gab es
die etwas linkere liberale partei die
ddp mein großvater hätte dort mehr
gleichgesinnte vorgefunden aber man hat
ihnen abgelehnt hat ihm seine haltung im
ersten weltkrieg vorgeworfen oder war ja
überzeugter nationalbewusstsein monarch
ist ja wie stand ihr großvater den ganz
generell zur republik von weimar war er
so etwas wie ein vernunft republikaner
das kann man sagen er ist er
aufgewachsen mit der monarchie und er
hat mal in seiner nobelpreisrede gesagt
das bestehen der monarchie war den
deutschen über viele hundert jahre mit
herz und hirn ein geschmiedet worden und
nach der novemberrevolution standen
diese menschen jetzt ohne basis ohne
kompass da es hat einige zeit gedauert
bis er sich mit der republik mit der
neuen staatsform angefreundet hat aber
dann glaube ich hat er sich umso mehr
dafür eingesetzt die stresemann auch als
erfinder eines ganz bestimmten anzuges
der nach ihm benannt worden ist
sprichwörtlich geworden wir sehen hier
ein bild wo er leider ein mantel darüber
trägt da was sie drunter hat ist der
sogenannte strahlemann
können sie uns die geschichte dazu
erzählen ja damals war es noch üblich
dass man bei offiziellen veranstaltungen
den sogenannten cut trug der kat hat
solange rockschöße wie wie bei einem
frack und das gefühl mein großvater
überhaupt nicht das fand eher
unpraktisch und zu steif und eines tages
beschloss er trägt jetzt auch ein
einfach klassisch mittellanges dunkles
jackett zu den übrigen outfit zu den
gestreiften hosen der der hellen weste
und damit hatte er
den stresemann erfunden das haben dann
viele gerne nach gemacht und nach dem
krieg auch adenauer und haben noch den
stresemann getragen nun hat hier dfd die
idee eine parteinahe stiftung eventuell
irgendwann einmal stresemann stiftungen
zu nennen wie stehen sie denn dazu da
habe ich überhaupt kein verständnis
dafür und werde auch mit meinem bruder
dagegen vorgehen die leistungen meines
großvaters das wofür er steht ist das
was er in den jahren 1923 bis 29
geleistet hat er gilt als europäischer
staatsmann also liberaler politiker auf
ausgleich bedacht gegenüber den anderen
staaten gemäßigten ton eine einbindung
deutschlands in einem europäischen
verbund suchend und für all das steht
die afg überhaupt nicht
[Musik]
der französische philosoph theodor vor
sagte einmal der schlüssel der
geschichte ist nicht in der geschichte
er ist den menschen nicht nur für
historiker und geschichtsinteressierte
ist das eine spannende frage was ist
entscheidend für den gang der geschichte
inwieweit mit geschichte vor allem auch
von menschen von großen männern und
frauen gemacht beschäftigen wir uns
deshalb mit einem weiteren prominenten
politiker der weimarer republik den
aller ersten reichspräsidenten friedrich
ebert hier in einer winzigen wohnung in
der pfaffengasse in der altstadt
heidelbergs wurde friedrich ebert im
jahre 1871 geboren er wuchs in kleinsten
verhältnissen aus friedrich ebert war
das siebte von neun kindern eines
schneidermeisters in heidelberg der
gelernte sattler wurde 1900 arbeiter
sekretär der spd
1912 kam er als abgeordneter der spd in
den reichstag 1913 wird er neben hugo
haase spd vorsitzender nach der
revolution und der spaltung der
sozialdemokraten in spd und spd wird er
zunächst leiter des rat der
volksbeauftragten dann für kurze zeit
reichskanzler nach den wahlen zur
nationalversammlung wird er in weimar im
februar 1919 zum ersten
reichspräsidenten der weimarer republik
gewählt
er stirbt im jahr 1925 eine zäsur in der
jungen republik
der historiker professor dr walter
mühlhausen ist geschäftsführer und
vorstandsmitglied der stiftung
reichspräsident friedrich ebert
gedenkstätte herr mühlhausen sie sind ja
ein ausgewiesener kenner sie haben auch
eine biografie über ihn geschrieben
wie würden sie denn seine
der kunst beschreibt ja das ist die
herkunft eines so ist eines kleinen
handwerker sondern ist schneider sohn
ist hier im milieu der kleine handwerker
arbeiter und tagungen heidelberg
inwiefern prägte friedrich edel denn in
seiner rolle als erster reichspräsident
die ersten jahre der republik von weimar
er war so etwas wie der stabilitätsanker
in dieser zeit man muss sich in
erinnerung gerufen dass ihnen diese
sechs jahren an denen wir an der spitze
der erste republik stand allein neun
kanzler ein und ausgingen
neben dem reichskanzler aus wir haben es
mit zwölf regierungen zu tun wie bei dem
sein bild in der damaligen
öffentlichkeit war er mehr praktika und
gewerkschaft oder auch gewissem sinne
theoretiker also er war kein theoretiker
sondern ein praktiker ein
reformpolitiker jährigen hier und heute
verbesserungen für die arbeiterschaft
durchsetzen wollte einer der sukzessive
zu einer besseren gesellschaft kommen
wollte deswegen darum möglichst ohne
große konflikte den weg in die republik
zu bahnen in ihre parlamentarische
demokratie das war sein ziel
und wem hat er sich alles andere
unterzuordnen ich für die demokratischen
war es wichtig dass jetzt ein zivilist
der nicht in pomp und gloria wie will
denn der zweite tag führte sondern
jemand der aus der arbeiter bewegung kam
der diesem abend eine besondere prägung
gab nämlich die eines zivilisten
für andere war ja einen nach oben
verirrter sozialdemokrat einer der
november verbrecher der praktisch
unrechtmäßig an der spitze des staates
stand
es gibt ja das berühmte foto dass ebert
zusammen mit dem reichswehr minister
gustav noske in badehosen zeigt können
sie uns die geschichte und die
reaktionen darauf mal beschreiben
es war ein privates foto was friedrich
ebert und gustav noske und andere der
sozialdemokratie aus hamburg beim baden
in der ostsee zeigt am strand fotograf
kam vorbei machte das foto und es wurde
dann irgendwie die berliner presse
gespielt und die berliner illustrirte
zeitung hat es dann exakt an dem tag zur
verteilung gebracht als viele hier über
den weimar auf die verfassung vereidigt
wurde daraus entwickelte sich ein
politischer skandal
denn die gesellschaft war es nicht
gewohnt dass die führenden politiker in
ihrem land sich in badehosen
präsentieren
das war ein appell an die allgemeine
befindlichkeit der deutschen jetzt war
man mühelos und sieht er die beiden
obersten repräsentanten der republik
lassen sich so ablichten
das ist kein zeichen der weimarer
republik dass die politiker der republik
sich massiven verleumdungen ausgesetzt
seien
so hat allein friedrich ebert über 200
prozesse gegen verloren da führen müssen
nicht immer mit erfolg
aber das war der einzige weg um sich
gegen diese maschinerie von diffamierung
und diskreditierung überhaupt zur wehr
zu setzen
was war denn so die bilanz seiner
gesamten amtszeit bis 19 25 er hat
seiner umfassenden machtbefugnisse als
reichspräsident die wesentlich mehr sind
als die des heutigen bundespräsidenten
zur stabilität der republik eingesetzt
zur verteidigung der demokratie und hat
damit dazu beigetragen dass wir uns ab
19 24 25 in einer so genannten phase der
stabilisierung in der weimarer republik
nach eders tod im jahre 1925 wurde ja
der vormalige feldmarschall paul von
hindenburg ist sein nachfolger im amt
wie würden sie denn die unterschiede
zwischen diesen beiden staatsoberhaupt
dann beschreiben die verfassung boot
eigentlich zwei möglichkeiten
einmal konnte der reichspräsident im
sinne der stabilisierung der demokratie
und der republik agieren
ein andermal konnte er seine
verfassungsrechtlichen möglichkeiten
auch gegen die republik verwenden friede
ebert handelte im sinne der ersten
interpretation die verfassungs
möglichkeiten für die stabilisierung
einzusetzen
paul von hindenburg sein nachfolger im
übrigen vom volke gewählt hat sich dann
gegen die republik gegen die demokratie
eingesetzt
[Musik]
im ersten weltkrieg wurde general später
generalfeldmarschall paul von hindenburg
als kriegsheld von tannenberg und retter
ostpreußens populär und zum symbol für
das kaiserliche deutschland er ist 77
jahre alt und im ruhestand als es sich
von einem konservativen parteienbündnis
für die reichspräsidenten wahlen im märz
1925 als kandidat aufstellen lässt und
gewinnt als zweiter reichspräsident der
weimarer republik wird er von vielen als
ersatzkaiser angesehen
in den krisenjahren ab 1930 nutzt der
monarchie ist hindenburg den
notverordnung artikel § 48 der
verfassung um einen nur von ihm
abhängigen reichskanzler einzusetzen
als diese präsidial kabinette mit den
reichskanzler brüning von paten und von
schleicher scheitern lässt sich
hindenburg neun monate nach seiner
wiederwahl im jahr 1932 überreden adolf
hitler zum reichskanzler zu ernennen
hierzu möchten wir noch mehr in
erfahrung bringen
das zeughaus ist das älteste gebäude auf
der straße unter den linden hier in
berlin mitte und hier befindet sich auch
das deutsche historische museum die
dauerausstellungen bringt mit mehr als
7000 objekten deutsche geschichte nach
davon auch viele aus der zeit der
weimarer republik
hier treffe ich ein gesprächsgast der
auch mal deutsches staatsoberhaupt war
christian wulff ist bundespräsident a d
herr bundespräsident die beiden
reichspräsidenten weimers friedrich
ebert paul von hindenburg waren in
sachen amtsverständnis und sich der
republik die sie repräsentierten ja
höchst unterschiedlich wenn wir uns treu
von hindenburg anschauen wie
entscheidend war er für das ende der
weimarer republik und für den gang in
die diktatur hindenburg hat sicher die
starke vorbelastung dass er selber an
der dolchstoßlegende
nach dem ersten weltkrieg aktiv
mitgewirkt hat dadurch belastet war ich
wirklich anhänger der demokratie war er
war auch als einzelner überfordert am
ende unter dem starken druck demokratie
feindlicher kräfte es fehlte an
demokraten
insofern hat er dann auch schuld auf
sich geladen aber auch seine verdienste
er zweimal adolf hitler nicht zum
reichskanzler ernannt und stand dann
auch sicher gewisser weise im nachgang
zu fehlern die auflösung des parlaments
neuwahlen zu einem denkbar ungünstigen
zeitpunkt ganz generell war in der
weimarer verfassung ja dem
reichspräsidenten eine enorme macht
zugewiesen worden war er da so etwas
hier ein ersatzkaiser also hinsichtlich
der stellung des reichspräsidenten in
der weimarer republik seiner befugnisse
seiner bedeutung auch ein
staatsoberhaupt war er gewissermaßen
ersatzkaiser natürlich überhaupt nicht
dahingehend dass er ja gerade der
verteidiger der republik zu sein hatte
und dadurch passt die formulierung dann
wieder nicht im vergleich zur weimarer
verfassung hat ihr das grundgesetz dem
amt des bundespräsidenten erheblich
weniger macht zu wiese war das für das
gelingen der demokratie unabdingbar
notwendig ich halte das ergebnis für
begrüßenswert dass man die
regierungschefin der regierungschef
aufgewertet hat das parlament ganz stark
aufgewertet hat dass man auch die justiz
sehr stark flankiert hat
also es von der einen person des
staatsoberhauptes weg geführt hat und
trotzdem können ein staatsoberhaupt in
entscheidenden phasen fibel wirken was
jetzt gerade unser aktueller
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
gezeigt hat als er seine partei aus der
entstand dann doch in die pflicht
genommen hatten nicht nach
parteipolitischen einen schätzen sich
nicht eine region zu beteiligen sondern
sich auch staatsbürger verantworten wenn
doch in die größte zeit zu bringen
also ich finde die heutige umschreibung
der aufgaben des bundespräsidenten für
sehr gelungen
nun wird ja immer wieder diskutiert dass
der bundespräsident nicht wie es eben
lange jahrzehnte war und ist von der
bundesversammlung gewählt wird sondern
vielleicht gegen einmal doch vom
deutschen volke direkt wie stehen sie
dazu
direkt gewählt wurde ja auch nur
hindurch als reichspräsident das endet
nicht so positiv und ich bin aus 2
gründen gegen die wahl des
bundespräsidenten durch das volk
einerseits würde es dann zu einem
wahlkampf kommen und in folge eines
wahlkampfes zwischen verschiedenen
kandidaten ist es für den gewählten
schwieriger alle hinter sich zu
versammeln da gibt es meistens narben
und wunden die zurückbleiben und das
andere ist dass eine direktwahl durchs
volk auch erhebliche erwartungen an den
gewählten beinhaltet denen er nach der
heutigen verfassung gar nicht gerecht
werden könnte man müsste dann die
befugnis wieder ausweiten das halte ich
aus den vorgenannten gründen nicht für
sinnvoll
aber wie stehen sie denn generell zum
thema direkte volksentscheide
das hatten die verfassungsväter 49 ja
abgelehnt wegen der erfahrung von weimar
aber sind fast 70 jahre bundesrepublik
grund morgen zu sagen wir können dem
deutschen volk wieder mehr vertrauen
auch in dem wir direkte demokratie da
und dort ermöglichen
in der schweiz funktioniert die
volksabstimmung deswegen muss man sie
ernst diskutieren
oft führt sie zur emotionalisierung von
themen und weg von der komplexität
dieser die umstellung auf der anderen
seite braucht man wohl neue
mitwirkungsmöglichkeiten wenn bürger
heute im internet jeden tag gefragt
werden nach ihrer meinung sie abgeben
können
dann werden sie auf dauer nicht
zufrieden denn wenn sie nur alle vier
fünf jahre zur wahlurne gerufen werden
und da müssen wir dinge ausprobieren
aber die letzte entscheidung beim
parlament für eine legislaturperiode hat
auch eben ihre vorteile gerade auch in
deutschland für die stabilität unseres
landes
sie hatten ja selbst das amt des
bundespräsidenten in wie würden sie denn
die bedeutung das wesen die chancen und
die möglichkeiten dieses amtes
beschreiben
ich glaube dass eine bundespräsidentin
ein bundespräsident das sehr ernst
nehmen sollte was am lübecker holstentor
steht eintracht nach innen frieden nach
außen ein großteil der arbeit des
bundespräsidenten ist außenpolitik er
vertritt die republik nach außen so
schnitzen grundgesetz mit der
bundesregierung und dem auswärtigen amt
nach innen für den zusammenhalt zu
sorgen durch ehrungen auszeichnungen
würdigungen auch trauer zu teilen nach
großen unglücksfällen also der
bundespräsident hat wird was sehr
konsensual alles zusammen führendes
gemeinsam vertreten des konsens
bildendes deswegen ist das amt auch so
unschätzbar wertvoll wenn wir noch
einmal zurück zu weimar gehen welche
rolle spielt denn die weimarer republik
aus ihrer sicht in der deutschen
demokratiegeschichte für mich gehört
weimar ganz klar in die linie 18 48 wird
dem gescheiterten letztlich
gescheiterten demokratie versuche 1918
erster gelungener demokratie versuch in
deutschland der dann leider nicht lange
dauerte und dann 1949 grundgesetz in
diese linie gehört weimar weimar war
eben der erste gelungene versuch und
daher die besondere würdigung die
weimarer verfassung war auch gut ich sie
war durchaus auch krisenfest
aber sie stand unter extrem negativen
vorzeichen sie hatte keinen
gründungsmythos sie hatte zu wenig
demokraten und man sollte sich daran
erinnern dass demokratie von den
griechischen dem auskommt volk
volksherrschaft und keine demokratie der
welt funktioniert am ende ohne
ausreichend viele bürgerinnen und bürger
aus dem volk die sich für diese
demokratie engagiert
die weimarer republik hatte zu wenig
demokraten in der mitte zu viel
radikaler an den rändern und in die lage
dürfen wir nie wieder kommen
der fokus liegt vor allem auf dem
scheitern der weimarer republik den
zahlreichen krisen und konflikten
dabei wird häufig übersehen dass damals
auch große kulturelle leistungen
erbracht wurden
generell wird er den mittleren jahren
den sogenannten goldenen zwanzigern
weniger beachtung geschenkt als dem
krisenhaften anfang und dem
folgenschweren ende so unrecht denn in
der zeit der weimarer republik macht
deutschland einen riesen sprung in die
moderne
vor allem in kunst und kultur nach dem
ersten weltkrieg gibt es eine
sprunghafte entwicklung für die
gesellschaft technik und wissenschaft
aber auch in kunst und kultur
architektur literatur und theater die
zeit prägt eine außergewöhnliche
experimentierfreude vor allem das radio
und das kino boomen mitte der
zwanzigerjahre strömen täglich rund zwei
millionen in die lichtspielhäuser
die universum film ag kurz ufa in
potsdam babelsberg ist nach hollywood
das zweitgrößte film imperium der welt
bei der ufa entstehen seinerzeit
klassiker der internationalen
filmgeschichte wie metropolis das
kabinett des doktor caligari oder
nosferatu mitten auf dem gelände in
babelsberg steht die marlene dietrich
halle in hand nach der berühmten
hauptdarstellerin mit der josef von
sternberg den ersten großen deutschen
tonfilm der blaue engel drehte
die halle wurde eigens 1926 für den
monumentalfilm metropolis errichtet hier
wurden hunderte nationale und
internationale filme gedreht wie zb
inglourious basterds um cloud atlas und
hier wurde auch die fernseh serie
babylon berlin gedreht sie spielt zur
zeit der weimarer republik babylon
berlin ist ein projekt der superlative
von der entwicklung der ersten bücher
bis zum sendebeginn vergingen
viereinhalb jahre
mit produktionskosten von knapp 40
millionen euro ist die serie die wohl
teuerste der deutschen tv-geschichte
regie führen
tomczyk war achim von borries und hank
hand leuchten christian dieser film
waren sie von eine spur
radikale kräfte aus allen richtungen
versuchen seit jahren den staat zu
unterhöhlen und das chaos in unsere
straßen zu tragen
aber wir haben die bürger unseres landes
und unsere demokratische verfassung zu
schützen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dies ist das delphi in berlin weißensee
zur zeit der weimarer republik war es
ein bekanntes stummfilmkino nun ein
drehort für babylon berlin
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hendrik hank handlichen ist
filmregisseur und drehbuchautor
und ich sehe hier serie auch ein bezug
auf diesen roman der nasse fisch von
volker kutscher haben sie sich bemüht
mit ihren kollegen gemeinsam das
möglichst naturgetreue zu verfehlen dann
haben sich auf freiheiten genommen wenn
ja welche freiheiten
naja also zunächst mal ist die reihe von
volker kutscher sind ja mehrere bücher
er hat eine sensationelle grundidee die
grundidee ist das ende der weimarer
republik zu erzählen im gewand eines
kriminalstücks darüber hinaus haben wir
dann aber gesagt okay wir wollen aber
noch mehr in die breite gehen wir wollen
eigentlich einen sittengemälde schaffen
derzeit wir wollen die zeit erfahrbar
machen und jedes gefühl zu haben man ist
in der damaligen zeit tatsächlich man
bewegt sich über die straßen der stadt
die er überhaupt nicht mehr existiert
das ist eigentlich das gefühl was wir
aus seinen büchern übernommen haben kann
man denn die themen die sie behandelt
haben in diesem film sind ja auch
zutiefst politische szene in irgendeiner
art und weise mit der situation heute
wird gleichen was meinen sie wie meinen
sie das erstarken des rechten spektrums
um sein dass das ist zum beispiel eine
sache immer wieder würde ich sagen dass
wir in deutschland ja zurzeit jedenfalls
recht gut dastehen und ich glaube dass
das tatsächlich mit den erfahrungen der
weimarer republik zu tun hat dh dass die
demokratie in deutschland im vergleich
zu anderen ländern auch innerhalb der eu
oder auch den usa oder auch
großbritannien auf eine art und weise
verhaftet ist in der parlamentarischen
demokratie ist meiner meinung nach
tatsächlich auch auf einmal
zurückzuführen auf diese erfahrungen der
totalen katastrophe und insofern würde
ich auch immer sagen dass unsere serie
gar nicht ein beitrag ist oder eine
unterhaltungsserie
wo man in zeitlupe angucken kann weder
demokratie langsam verändert sondern
eher das gegenteil dass man sagt okay
das geht eigentlich eher um den kampf
für die demokratie wenn man heute sagt
in der zeit der weimarer republik boomte
die kunst und die kultur szene vor allem
auch nicht zuletzt im film ist das ein
klischee oder stimmt das wirklich was
meinen sie also ich glaube dass das
wirklich zutrifft je mehr man darüber
liest und erfährt ist es wirklich
unglaublich wie modern diese stadt genau
diese stadt auch war und eben auch nicht
nur in der kunst und kultur sondern eben
wir heute wissen schaffen alle waren sie
hier
ein steinmeier heisenberg und wie sie
alle heißen also die ganze
wissenschaftler war ja auch so
wahnsinnig avanciert und es im griff
alles zusammen und man hört auch mal
wieder wie das dass es sehr viele
überschneidungen gab ja also dass das
einstein eben auch mit fritz lang
zusammen traf und das muss ja zu etwas
geführt haben und ich glaube also auch
die modernität unglaublich man denkt
irgendwie man ist immer noch nicht
wieder da also wie weit die die stadt
damals war es ist unglaublich
das waren ja wohl doch auch nicht
zuletzt die jüdische künstler die die
kunst kultur und filmszene prägten
damals nicht nur da sondern natürlich
auch eine ganz großer teil der
ärzteschaft ganz großer teil der anwälte
der us justiz war
mit juden setzt berlin war eine eine
stadt voller vibrierende energie und
manchmal denkt man das ist sehr sehr
ähnlich wie heute aber in zwei sachen
unterscheidet sich die stadt heute
vollkommen zunächst mal gibt es heute
das internet was es nicht gab
das ist tatsächlich eine errungenschaft
wird man das möchte
und der ganz großer unterschied zu
damals der jüdische geist und der
jüdische witz ist für immer dahin
stichwahl modernität nehmen wir
beispiele wie die filme metropolis oder
später dann auch der blaue engel hat
filme wie diese auch ein einfluss auf
den film heute der film der weimarer
republik war ja zum größten teil noch
stummfilm bis auf drei jahre am schluss
noch und das sind unglaublich prägende
bilder die auch irgendwo im kollektiven
unterbewusstsein herumgeistern
übrigens nicht nur im deutschen sondern
auch international wie wir jetzt wissen
wenn man die augen zumacht und wenn uns
verraten denn sieht man sofort ein paar
bilder und das ist lustigerweise im
ausland unheimlich stark verbunden mit
german angst
und wenn man sich die filme angeguckt
diese bilder die sie haben die sind auch
immer noch absolut eigen ja und aber
irgendwie auch vertrauen
wie bewerten sie aus ihrer sicht das
filmschaffen
die weimarer republik was ist für sie
das erbe von weimar das erbe ist auf
eine unglaublich freie hedonistische
lebenspralle art daran erinnert zu
werden da hoffentlich bedeutet irgendwie
dass man den anderen achtet und dass man
hier sein lässt wie ihr alter ist
die kulturelle blüte steht jedoch im
krassen gegensatz zu der sozialen und
wirtschaftlichen lage im land mit der
weltwirtschaftskrise 1929 beginnt der
untergang der weimarer republik
rezession massenarbeitslosigkeit und
hyperinflation führen zu not sozialem
elend und radikalisierung auf den
straßen toben blutige kämpfe im
reichstag zerbricht 1930 die große
koalition über einen streit über die
reform der arbeitslosenversicherung bei
den wahlen legen die radikalen kräfte
drastisch zu im reichstagsgebäude ist
heute der sitz des parlaments des
wiedervereinigten deutschlands in der
weimarer republik quartier das frei und
demokratisch gewählte parlament
nach der zeit der nationalversammlung in
weimar am 24 juni 1920 zum ersten mal
zusammen
thomas oppermann ist vizepräsident des
deutschen bundestages
was erinnert hier im reichstagsgebäude
an die erste deutsche demokratie wie
präsent ist die weimarer republik hier
die ist natürlich die man auch sehr
präsent denn der reichstag war der
schauplatz der weimarer demokratie
hier fanden die parlamentarischen
debatten statt und vom anfang der
republik bis zum ende der republik haben
wir natürlich sehr markante
erinnerungszeichen es gibt heute noch
den west balkon von dem aus philipp
scheidemann am mittag des neunten
november die republik ausgerufen hat und
wir haben einen erinnerungsraum in dem
in drei bänden die kurzbiografien von
120 reichstagsabgeordneten niedergelegt
sind die der nationalsozialistischen
gewaltherrschaft zum opfer gefallen sind
und wir haben natürlich immer noch den
plenarsaal der heute ganz anders die
moderne aussieht aber es ist der gleiche
raum
gleichwohl gibt es ja unterschiede
zwischen dem reichstag
der weimarer republik und dem deutschen
bundestag heute welche sind es denn vor
allem aus ihrer sicht also der bundestag
ist ein stabiles parlament im reichstag
der weimarer zeit hatten wir eine
zersplitterung von parteien es war
schwierig regierungen zu bilden und das
ist vielleicht auch eine lehre für heute
dass der hauptunterschied zwischen den
parteien der weimarer republik und den
parteien heute die kompromissfähigkeit
oder nicht kompromissfähigkeit
oder sehen sie noch andere grundlegende
unterschiede der pragmatik der
programmatik unbedingt max weber spricht
ja bei den parteien von gesinnungs
parteien auf der einen seite und
gestaltungs parteien auf der anderen
seite die parteien der bonner republik
sind gestaltungspartei die eben auch
verantwortung für das ganze gemeinwesen
übernehmen jedenfalls die volkspartei
die sich nicht als klientel parteien
verstehen
in weimar hatten wir gesinnungs parteien
die kompromissen fähig waren die wollten
ihre weltanschauung durchsetzen und
sonst gar nichts
und wir haben auch heute mit der afg
eine partei die eine klassische
gesinnungs partei ist und die demokratie
braucht parteien die kompromissbereit
sind und nicht nur maximal ist ische
ambitionen hat man ist in diesen tagen
ja oft von weimar oder weimarer
verhältnissen die rede
sehen sie denn zum beispiel in den
auseinandersetzung und ausschreitungen
in chemnitz irgendwelche parallelen die
anwohner erinnern können
ich finde dass die vorfälle in chemnitz
deshalb besorgniserregend sind weil weil
da eigentlich die botschaft vermittelt
worden ist der migrations konflikt und
das ist ja ein großer konflikt in
unserer gesellschaft spaltet unsere
gesellschaft die auf die reise nach
kräften auf dieser welle und versucht
stimmung zu machen dass dieser konflikt
auf der straße aus
getragen werden soll und das ist
natürlich wenn sie so wollen eine
erinnerung 1 reimer
da hatten wir straßenschlachten das
hatten die auseinandersetzungen nicht
mehr im parlament statt am ende sondern
auf der straße es gab gewalt und es gab
kompromiss unfähigkeit davon sind wir
heute weit entfernt aber es darf nicht
dazu kommen und da sehe ich dann doch
eine neue qualität dass das
gewaltmonopol des staates in frage
gestellt wird wir dürfen nicht wieder
zurückkehren zum recht des stärkeren die
nazis die wollten das rechte stärkeren
durchsetzen und das haben sie am ende
auch geschafft und damit haben sie die
demokratie zerstört wenn wir über
deutschland mal hinaus schauen da sehen
wir in europa aufkommen
rechtspopulistischer parteien
wir sehen halb autokratische herrscher
wir sehen ein putin erdogan
wir sehen auch einen präsidenten in den
usa der sich von alten bündnissen gerne
lösen möchte ist das ein zeichen von
krise in demokratischen gesellschaften
des westens ist die demokratie in diesen
gesellschaften sozusagen auch bedroht ja
ich glaube die demokratie ist ohnehin
nichts was man einmal hat und dann immer
behält
es genügt nicht die demokratie unserer
verfassung festzuschreiben sondern
demokratie das ist kein dauerzustand
sondern etwas was man sich permanent neu
erarbeiten muss wofür man kämpfen muss
und man muss die spielregeln auch immer
wieder durchsetzen indem man die
menschen davon überzeugt dass die
demokratie wie helmut schmidt das mal
gesagt hat oder virtual die demokratie
ist vielleicht die schlechteste aller
staatsformen aber es gibt bis heute
keine besser gesagt helmut schmidt hat
wiederholt die republik steht am abgrund
reichspräsident von hindenburg macht vom
notverordnung artikel § 48 gebraucht es
beginnt die zeit der präsidial kabinette
eine rechtskonservative anti
republikanische canaria nimmt zunehmend
einfluss auf den reichspräsidenten
das verbot von as a und s es wird wieder
aufgehoben
die geschäftsführende regierung in
preußen wird im sogenannten preußen
schlag entmachtet und der
reichsregierung unterstellt die
geschichtswissenschaft interpretiert
dies als staatsstreich auf raten die
demokratie wird zerstört
am 30 januar 1933 and hindenburg adolf
hitler zum reichskanzler
dies ist das ende der weimarer republik
und der beginn der
nationalsozialistischen diktatur
professor dreier summa summarum was
waren ihrer ansicht nach die gründe für
das scheitern der weimarer republik
ich würde den begriff scheitern
eigentlich gar nicht so gern verwenden
ich würde ja von der zerstörung der
weimarer republik reden scheitern
impliziert dass die ware republik selbst
irgendwie dafür verantwortlich war und
das auch in der tat lange zeit
herrschende meinung in der wissenschaft
gewesen
das ist irgendwie die strukturfehler der
konstruktionsfehler dabei republik waren
aber ich denke inzwischen hat sich in
der wissenschaft weitgehend durchgesetzt
das ist eine zerstörung war und nicht
ein scheitern der republik
also was sie einmal gesagt wurde
fünf-prozent-klausel fehlte parteien
waren problem also alles richtig
weltwirtschaftskrise das ist alles
richtig aber lassen sich die zentralen
ursachen
das ist eine bewusste zerstörung am ende
der republik gewesen
egal wo sie hinkommen in der politik in
der wirtschaft in der justiz im militär
in den akademischen bereichen medien und
der intellektuellen
wir haben mittlerweile republik eine
sehr starke gruppe die von vornherein
anti republikanische und
antidemokratisch ist die wollten
natürlich nicht klar haben das ist klar
aber sie wollten die republik anschaffen
und allem durch ein autoritäres regime
ersetzen wesentliche gründe für das
aufkommen hitlers waren ja unter anderem
doch die weltwirtschaftskrise und die
würde
im anschluss wie wichtig für die
stabilität eines demokratischen systems
sind denn ganz generell über die zeiten
hinweg wirtschaftliche stabilität und
soziale sicherheit
die sind natürlich wichtig das ist klar
eine demokratie braucht auch etwas los
die den bürgern zeigen kann und soziale
sicherheit ist ein zentrales element
davon nur die wirtschaftliche lage war
ja in ländern wie frankreich und
großbritannien und gerade in den usa
auch nicht besser als in deutschland
und da hat die demokratie gehalten da
ist es nicht so passiert wie da war
immer eure publik was natürlich daran
lag dass ist in diesen ländern keine
jedenfalls nicht in der größenordnung
wie in deutschland antidemokratische und
anti republikanischen kräfte im lande
gab die das politische system bewusst
zerstört worden also wirtschaft ist
wichtig aber das ist sicherlich nicht
der einzige faktor der alle rolle spielt
wie wichtig ist denn aus heutiger sicht
die geschichte der weimarer republik und
die sicht darauf
ich denke die es inzwischen wichtiger
geworden als wir uns das gewünscht
hätten vor ein paar jahren hätte ich
wahrscheinlich weitestgehend gesagt na
ja das ist ein wichtiger historischer
epochen der deutschen geschichte
inzwischen gibt es ja leute davon reden
dass man das system merkel beenden
musste
dafür gibt es methoden die nennt man
wahlen in einer republik in einer
demokratie und das ist eine rhetorik die
ja doch sehr stark an die rhetorik der
republik gegner und demokratie gehe ich
mal in der weimarer republik das heißt
sie waren mal publik zeigt uns sehr
drastisch dass demokratie nicht
selbstverständlich ist dass ich mich vom
baum fällt irgendwie sondern das ziel
ständig wieder neu errungen werden muss
1795 hat der mann unerkannt in einer
schrift zum ewigen frieden den klugen
satz gesagt der friede muss gestiftet
werden
und das gilt auch für die demokratie das
gilt auch für die republik die sind
nicht natürlich sondern sie müssen immer
wieder neu gestiftet werden und bewahrt
werden und die weimarer republik ist ein
beispiel dafür was passiert wenn das
nicht geschieht ist die demokratie in
deutschland heute gefährde
ich würde ich sagen gefährdet aber
gefährdet herr als vor zehn jahren auf
jeden fall so sind entwicklungen
passiert in den letzten jahren die
problematisch sind allerdings glaube ich
dass wir eine stabile demokratie haben
wir sind am ende unserer spurensuche
angelangt 100 jahre nach beginn der
weimarer republik steht fest die erste
deutsche republik und ihre verfassung
sind ein wichtiger und wertvoller teil
der deutschen demokratiegeschichte das
schicksal der weimarer republik mahnt
uns wie fragil demokratie und freiheit
sind
berlin ist weit davon entfernt weimar zu
sein
aber demokratie braucht das engagement
und die unterstützung der bürgerinnen
und bürger und vor allem wachsamkeit
das ist das wichtigste aber der weimarer
republik
[Musik]